filmmaking is not math it's Jeff yeah
yeah that's a Todd thing okay Todd says
I just love saying it I remember him
saying that like ages ago
like I don't know three movies ago but I
just love it it's like is such a great
expression because we were talking about
somebody we had both worked with who was
super scientific about the way he would
add in a movie in the way he would treat
even jokes and it was like if the joke
works it would get made in the movie but
almost like it was just it was it was
where you were trying to turn filmmaking
into math that I think Todd was like
yeah it's like you can't one plus one
doesn't equal two in filmmaking it's
just something different you want one
plus one frankly to equal three you
wanted to be greater than the sum of its
parts
and there's an intangible in there that
is the the missing one right and that
intangible is like the thing that is the
jazz it's the it's the being super
present when you're making a movie and
watching everybody else move and just
which is what jazz is right like when
they start when jazz starts it doesn't
know where it's going doesn't know where
it ends and everybody has to really be
in sync and watch each other and find
their own place within the song right so
you you just like it's amazing when you
watch them they just one guy takes over
and suddenly has like a little solo on
the drums and then it switches back into
like all four pieces working together
and then suddenly now the trumpet as a
solo and all that ways in which
everybody has a place to shine but
you're still working as a group and and
and the fact that you don't necessarily
know where it's going I think it's just
a cool way to think about filmmaking is
that you have this structure which is
your screenplay and your plan but that
you really should just just sometimes
just feel it out and and and that way
it'll allow you to discover a new piece
of music that you didn't write before
then right it's like then it becomes
something brand new and that's the part
of it that I really love that expression
how did that happen on Joker
well that was sort of that thing of of
not rehearsing and not you know and just
just you know we started getting to the
place of this rolling the minute Martine
would walk into the room kind of thing
and so sometimes you just would roll
into it and you know you knew the
structure who's gonna be writing his
journal or he's gonna do this because
you still have to tell a story linearly
enough that you know you're tracking all
the things you want to track otherwise
the movie can feel too improvisational
right like and then it starts to feel a
bit you know meandering and lost and
some of those movies can work but I also
like you know when a movie has a certain
that you are following enough of a
structure that you're telling a very
specific story now within the body of
that specific structure you can be
improvisational and have some of that
jazz right which is just to allow the
actor enough freedom to be able to do
what they want to do and not bound it
into something where you know and that's
where the other actors that would have
to act against Joaquin would also have
to stay in that rhythm and that you know
and and you'd watch some actors who'd do
it beautifully I thought that Brian
Tyree Henry who did it immaculately well
because it's just an example of the
rhythm and the way in which were Keane
would drive a scene was always different
and just his pacing and even if the
words were similar it was just the way
in which he would work that that you
know Brian had to stay in sync with that
and sometimes we would intentionally
that scene we intentionally cross shot
which is not something most dps would go
to normally because it's somewhat
compromising right where you actually
shoot both people at the same time right
normally you should one at a time then
the other person cut them against each
other simply because you can just
control the lighting and then and they
can compromise each other if you do this
but we shot that scene purposely at the
same time cross shooting it with two
cameras because knowing that if what
Keane was gonna do something that was a
little off-base we wouldn't necessarily
want to have to replicate it on the
other side so we want to have the
time you know reaction of who tried to
do that as much as possible and so you
know and a lot of them a lot of the
movie as you know one or two people and
seeing so sometimes that was a little
bit easier to do but if we could shoot
the two people we we did it simply so
that you know we didn't have to feel
like suddenly Joaquin had to match
something when he did it on the other
person's coverage so that was a big part
of like allowing that improvisation to
happened so we can do very few takes but
Joaquin had the freedom to know that
that it was being captured and whatever
he did with that freedom would Joaquin
ask questions about the character or was
it just it was like he had already he
knew Arthur so well oh I mean there are
so many smoke breaks between Todd and
Joaquin there are a lot of questions
that's its own movie right there yeah be
rollin oh I know just like just the the
cigarette break
the yeah I mean that's the beauty of
being a director and and certainly is
they have conversations that are like
wonderful and myriad of stuff that and
I'm frankly not necessarily always privy
to so I think they talked for hours I
they talked after hours there were a lot
of questions and a lot of conversations
about who the character was that's all
in there it's not like Joaquin had a
very keen sense and then that was it and
we shot for 58 days that they were
adjusting it all the time it's I think
one of the things that Todd does really
well there's also just that he's he's
super fluid as far as recognizing the
movie is being made every day and you're
discovering what the movie is every day
you have a plan but you're really making
the movie day by day and and it's
adjusting day by day so you know you're
making adjustments to the character and
you're discovering new things about the
character and and all of these things
and so that's happening all the time and
Todd is really good about allowing that
to happen because I think it's a really
good trait and a director is too
be so single-minded and focused on your
plan that you lose sight of potentially
a better plan
you